Sky's correspondent Emma birchley is in
Southend on sea for us now Emma how are
things looking where you are people
embracing the Heat
like most certainly are there's barely a
wisp of cloud in the sky glorious
temperatures a lovely cooling breeze and
I'm clearly not the only one to think it
because this place is getting busier by
the minute seven miles of seafront here
in South End there's a pier the longest
pier in the world Leisure Pier at 1.3
miles in length and actually if you go a
few uh miles up the road you can get on
an airplane at Southend airport that'll
take you to various holiday destinations
and in Malaga in the south of Spain it's
not going to be as hot as it is here in
south end where the temperatures may hit
around 27 degrees and actually South End
isn't alone
across much of the country there is one
of these UK Health Security Agency heat
Health alerts in place so much of the
country's got a yellow warning here in
the east of England London the southeast
it's called an amber alert so the
chances are that we will get a heatwave
if that means that certain temperatures
have to be met for three consecutive
days at least actually the hottest day
is expected to be on Tuesday where
temperatures are expected to get into
the low 30s and all the warnings come
with that so we're all being told to
stay out of the Sun in the middle of the
day clearly lots of people ignoring that
also stay hydrated and you've got to do
water soft drinks no booze don't be
tempted by the beer Sun cream sun hats
and at home keep your curtains drawn the
Windows shut it might seem
counter-intuitive but it will keep your
home cooler and finally one thing to say
here in south end it's due to be 22
degrees at 10 o'clock tonight so that's
going to be tricky for sleeping and
there is this tip about putting your
pillowcase in your pajamas in the
freezer doesn't tempt me I have to say
but apparently it'll help you get off to
sleep more easily and hopefully stay
asleep